c'est la nouvelle routine de la famille
racicot a 90 ans roland se bat contre la
coved 19 depuis trois semaines au centre
d'hébergement yvon brunelle ici 65 % des
résidents sont infectés ces infirmières
au front dévoués comme karine ont besoin
de renfort et c'est ce que viennent
offrir les forces armées canadiennes
on a fait notre première visite puis mon
but c'est vraiment la reconnaissance
l'auditeur ainsi devancé quoi leur
besoin vraiment sur le terrain puis moi
qu'est ce que je peux leur apporter en
respectant mes capacités
les qualifications varient mais la
centaine de militaires qui seront
déployés ont tous une formation médicale
il y aura des infirmières est ce que
l'armée appelle des techniciens médicaux
quand elle vraiment le de la main
d'oeuvre pour aider les préposés aux
bénéficiaires
c'est que les soins aux patients
n'auraient les laver leur parler jouent
aux cartes sont vraiment le poteau 5 6 h
et celle d où les besoins sont criants
ont été identifiés tous dans la région
de montréal
l'oeil de la tempête au pays mais
déploiement devrait commencer dans les
prochains jours mais c'est pas déterminé
encore les jours exactement
et naturellement nous on va leur donner
une formation de base passe comme elle
nous disait tantôt noir ne pas lésiner
serment le travail avec des personnes
âgées la formation est déjà toute prête
une fois que la marque et sur nos
visages on ne touche plus à notre visage
des formations pour les bénévoles la
croix rouge et le cius de l'ouest de
l'île en donne aussi des gens qui ont
pas nécessairement de formation médicale
mais qu'ils disent moi je vois ça le
télé je veux aider
on prévoit quand même fournir à peu près
40 nouvelles personnes par jour a pour
l'instant un programme est vraiment 7
jours sur 7
donc c'est 40 par jour sept jours sur
sept et ya pas de date de fin prévue
pas de date comme pour la fin de
l'épidémie contact mme un apaisement dit
girard blaye pour le personnel qui
s'occupe de sa soeur sans relâche depuis
un mois et si jacques houde richard de
noray du canada la sarre